المنتخب الارجنتيني يخرج الان من الطائره
لاستقبالهم كاستقبال الافضل
اذا نتابع معكم هذه الصور مباشره من وينو
ايرس حيث يستعد افراد المنتخب الارجنتيني
للنزول من مدرج هذه الطائره نتابع معكم
اذا لحظه وصول المنتخب الارجنتيني وهبوط
الطائره التي وصلت من الدوحه الى بوينوس
ايرس بعد مرور اكثر من شهر من بقائها في
العاصمه الدوحه حيث وصلوا الان والجماهير
الارجنتين
لاستكمال الاحتفالات بعد حصولهم عندنا
نجوى الثالثه وفوز لهم ليه المره الثالثه
المنتخب الارجنتيني بعد فوزهم في مونديال
قطر 20 22 وهزيمتهم للمنتخب الفرنسي في
مباراه عظيمه مجنونه اقل ما يقال عنها
وعلى كل حال الاحتفالات كانت بدات منذ
لحظه تتويج ميسي وفريق منتخب الارجنتين
حيث في منطقه المسله في بوينوس ايرس كنا
نتابع هذه الاحتفالات المليونيه بعد ان
حصل الارجنتين على اللقب فائز في كاس انا
عيني على ميسي
يخرج من الطائره في هذه اللحظات حامله كاس
العالم بعد انتظار الارجنتين 36 عاما
نستمع لهذه اللحظات تاريخيه
عمري
[موسيقى]
منذ ان وطئت قدما نجم الارجنتيني ليونيل
ميسي ارض بوينوس حتى بدات الاحتفالات وكان
ميسي نام وفي حضنه هذا الكاس الذهبي الذي
حلم به وحلمت به الارجنتين بعد اكثر من 36
عاما حيث تسلمت الارجنتين النجمه الثالثه
بعد ان فازت بمونديال قطر 20 22 نتابع
معكم اذا هذه الصور والاحتفالات ستكون
مستمره في العاصمه وايضا في المدن
الارجنتينيه كافه
الرئيس الارجنتيني ايضا سيكون بانتظارهم
الذي حضر المباراه النهائيه
بس المرمى وشفنا فرحه ميسي يا نادين اللي
ضافها الى الانجاز التاريخي يقولوا بحصوله
لاول مره على كاس العالم يضيف هذا الشيء
لرصيده لبطولات حصل عليها والقاب كذلك قاد
الارجنتين وقاده منتخب ويلي فوز تاريخه
الثالث في تاريخ الارجنتين بعد عام 1986
طبعا لو
انا اللي بمسي لماذا لان هذا هو الفرصه
هذه هي الفرصه الاخيره
لهشارك في مونديال كاس العالم بعد ان بلغ
من العمر 36 عاما هناك عمر
نهايه العمر بالنسبه للاعب الفوتبول حيث
يتجاوز اسد 36 عاما لا تسمح له بان يستكمل
ويمضي بالتالي
غريب الذي حزن كثيرا وظهر عليه ايضا الحزن
والغضب بعد خساره المنتخب الفرنسي الى ان
امامه حوالي يعني ثلاثه مونديالات ليه
يحصل على اللقب ويحقيقه
والجوائز حصل سبع مرات على الكره الذهبيه
حصل على الحذاء الذهبي في كره القدم وتوج
كل هذه الالقاب في ختام مسيرته الرياضيات
بحصوله على كاس العالم المنتظر منه اخيرا
ليصبح من اعظم لاعب كره القدم في التاريخ
اضافه الى مارادونا
بالتاكيد سنكون معكم في سياق نشرات
العربيه
لديد الاحتفالات اولا باولا على شاشه
العربيه لاحتفالات الجماهير الارجنتينيه
بعد وصول لمنتخبنا الفائز بكاس العالم وسط
هذه الاحتفالات الكبيره وطبعا بدات
الاغاني وبدات التصفيق لحظه تاريخيه ميسي
حامل
مثل ما هو فعلا ههه
الكاس لميسي وميسي الكاس يستاهل
يستاهل تاريخيا ميسي الاسطوره ميسي يحمل
كاس العالم 20 22
منتخب الارجنتين الفائز بكاس العالم
[موسيقى]
طبعا الحضور في هذا
المطارس وبدات هذه الحفله التي ستنقل
المنتخب الارجنتيني يعني كم الساعه الان
هي الساعه ربما مساء سنحاول ان نبحث
التوقيت
الان وطبعا ليست فقط الارجنتين هي التي
تحتفل وايضا العديد من المدن العربيه
خالده ميسي الكثير من الجماهير العرب
متابع معكم طبعا الساعه الثالثه بتوقيت
القاهره
لم تكن ولم تمل تريد الاحتفال تريد ان
تشعر به الفخر بان منتخب بلادها حقق الفوز
وبعد ان نجح وتعب في اكثر من مباراه في
مونديال قطر 22 رغم ان المباراه الاخيره
مع المنتخب الفرنسي يعني كانت وصفت بانها
جنونيه فوق الخيال حيث وصفت الكره بانها
مثل الحياه الكره غداره في كل 10 دقائق
تتغير النتيجه وتتغير معها المعادله ميسي
يقول الارجنتين
للفوز بكاس العالم للمره الثالثه في
تاريخها في تاريخها بعد النهائي مجنون ضد
المنتخب الفرنسي كان هاترك مواصفات وفازت
الارجنتين بي ركلات الترجيح لتقتنيس كاس
العالم 20 22 فقط ميسي يعتبر افضل هداف
للارجنتين في تاريخ كاس العالم اول لاعب
في التاريخ المونديال في جميع ادوار بطوله
قطر
كاس العالم